o cucina tutto gioco attirato pulito che
ho affidato le camicie poi giustamente
neanche un bacio 0 affetto beni perché
così presente per niente o no no meglio
che farlo cittadino prima di partire
bene
metti che ha giocato tutte e ravioli ora
è chiamato a tulli ha risposto ma sicuri
che non provi più niente per lui no
perché mette 12 mila pezzi
domani shopping giuridico di tutti i
social e se proprio ci volta ci facciamo
partire di coppia se ti fa stare più
tranquilla lo giuro è durata soltanto
famiglie fra polacchi a vecchie che non
vedrai mai un laico latifah lo giuro
retour à regione troppo diverse spiace
che ti amo più della mia vita
ma pensate un po fastidio ma perché lo
devi farti ma perché prima che parlare
capitolo cambiata fino a morire davvero
ghiotta
se un cretino
nella mia vita senza di te non ha alcun
senso io ti amo troppo e allora faccia
media amore domenica siamo pranzo dai
miei
poi ci siamo sempre ungere concentrano
ci sono una partita tutto organizzato
perché trovati biglietti tribuna d'onore
e buffe tutto pagato oggi vediamo mai e
lui poi così sono più
francini domenica non ci sono una foto
con cubista ma ti rendi conto
non so neanche chi è il genio 25 anni
con un piano che appunto ci siamo capiti
mandiamo gestiva una cosa del genere
voleva marzo 2013
quattro svedesi contro queste norme è un
ragazzo in mezzo quando un po 21
incredibile
allora visto che senti io ti ho
perdonato e si è detto amore non
vogliono mira tutto per una foto però
profeta commutativa adesso today
perdonarmi cuscino to me l'amore
basta non ce la faccio più elevate che
risolto certo punti veramente che adesso
mi ricordo tipo mai detto guarda che ti
dimentica politica andando a letto
allora vi obiettivo tutti gli uomini che
dobbiamo dire poche no e noi lì che ti
fa
carattere